so I made a post and I'm not sure you
know really as the post read the post I
said the amount of times that I've had
to fake an AZ in order to stop him on
them good times well there's not not
really and when women would ask me if I
had arrived
I'd throw away the good times I'd flush
it down the toilet like a corrupt cop
hiding evidence and this is the last
place I said good times protects you
from STDs and fun that was the gist of
my post now I had some angry people hit
me up
Oh Ava you're shaming women who want
protection no I recognize the necessity
in the importance of using protection it
doesn't change the fact that I don't
enjoy it I don't enjoy the way that it
feels it really does ruin the experience
for me in some cases not always but
sometimes especially when you get the
wrong type of country yo
I feel nothing it cuts off the
circulation you know there I'm just
relating to you guys my experience in a
humorous way it should be that deep but
people got really upset and one girl in
particular yeah one in particular
all right she wrote me and she said come
on this is such little pee nor energy
yeah and I was like what me just sharing
to you what I experienced and the fact
that I don't like it is such little Wow
and so I would like I'm like yeah well
you got loose pump--ow energy and she's
like oh what a ethiopian thing to say
yo she double saved you she double she
double change you that's the thing
here's the thing right you know all
right
it's like body positivity well then when
it comes to men
you'll shame them on their vices isn't
that interesting she's interesting is it
true
did you know what and I say this as
someone who never think of shaming other
people for their size you know we did
that you know big Edie no neck add
whatever that was the nickname big yeah
I never made fun of him for whatever
kind of dysmorphia is in his body
because to me is just like I mean
everything they're doing that to me it's
not appealing but women shall be
dropping in my gm's
and sometimes they'd be having these
foul things to sound like whoo whoo you
have to look here in the city
but when you receive clap
you cannot handle it oh my god why are
you so defensive me me me me yo no don't
come up in my DM talking yeah so you
know it was just interesting to hear
people and I find the whole you know
little peon or energy I just like why
would you say that to people oh yeah yay
you just seem like you got a fragile ego
you got a little P nor energy what I
ever think of going to a girl like you
got loose poom poom energy of course not
if a girl's be in France like you're
fragile but we love to shame men on the
size of their fouls because we recognize
that it go against their ideas of
masculinity so like you know what I know
how to hurt him I'm gonna tell he's got
a smoke even though it's not true what I
find offensive is that you feel so
comfortable saying that but when I say
the opposite to you you're like oh
you're such a bad person I just did what
you did do not see that no she didn't
see that she didn't see that the comfort
that they go sliding to say something
like yes crazy young and after that she
double she doubles down yeah Oh
Ethiopia that's assassin nothing to do
with that it was a response exactly what
you said oh wait she what I just
realized
what did you do she's Ethiopian too it
doesn't matter
so it really wasn't he still good thing
to do since we both did it and we're
both Ethiopian I have a little Pino
energy but I got big forehead energy too
let's go for hit be it's not that big no
we got pretty similar size tomorrow the
proportion I got probably a bigger head
and you yeah yeah I got a bigger head
again but I got more real estate where
it matters I'm just saying you know I
mean if I want to move in a little
suburban family up here I can take you
in a couple yeah you coulda taken a
couple closer the mountain let's go
affordable housing right here the
projects when you sweat there's a little
river or something like that all of it
yeah yes are you going on little changes
oh it was great yeah guys be more
mindful of like the kind of rhetoric you
guys say that's all it is it's pretty
much you know like I'm not I'm not
butthurt about the whole thing it was
just like the hypocrisy made me laugh
and I see it all the time
little little
more energy you got why would you save
people on the sides of their house like
I go through so much trouble in my life
to make sure that women don't feel
self-conscious about like their smells
down there you know their body size
because you know women really deal with
a lot of problems when it comes to their
self-image and yet you feel so
comfortable to use that kind of language
and think it's perfectly acceptable just
interesting to me let's be more
consistent in our values there's no
problem going in someone as d-m but if
you act stupid
be ready to suffer the wrath and there's
gonna be my right to do that yeah you're
gonna go outside your way to go in my DM
- yeah girl yeah got it here yeah yeah
we cannot and I've seen that during the
protest that we're going on Oh Ross ISM
is little energy it's like yo you're
shaming a whole bunch of thing but you
want me us to respect and everything as
the for you're the one shaming other
people and stuff like that there's a
thing that's going on out there where
guys without the content of the girl
remove the condoms right and keep on
going
that is disgusting and but that's not
what we're talking about and I know that
that's where they got from you don't
care where they got no I didn't say that
I agree no you didn't say that at all
you know what and the reality is this
yes and as a woman you cannot comprehend
that because you don't have to
understand the condom
you know I mean just a protection the
protection you don't understand what
there's some pros and there's some cons
to that it is and it's a fact because
every time you watch a commercial about
protection that's what they tell you
they're always really now really thin
new sensation ribbed why do you think
that is because there's a lack in that
and that's a fact because you might set
up these try you know it is and it's a
fact it is and it's a reality it is a
reality so now we can't speak reality is
that what it is we can't say outside of
the story is that what it is at no point
during my discourse did I shame anyone
who wants to use it or say hey don't
because the necessity is still there
right it's like wearing your seat belt I
mean I like it but I still wear it
because I understand it's important all
right there's a whole bunch of stuff
that I do that despite not wanting to do
it you know what I hate about food belts
uh-huh some sounds like when are you
sitting in the back
and that thing locked yeah cuz the
personhood unloosen it does it does that
that's how I'm gonna raise my kids right
if I talk to them about drugs I'm not
gonna say drugs or bad and try to scare
them and to know I'm gonna try to give
them the reality listen drugs can lead
to that they're really bad stuff but
people take it for recreational stuff or
just to be happy and stuff like that you
have to be conscious of what you're
doing and what you're getting at because
they could easily fall into that other
thing I'm not gonna tell them drug is
just bad and it's just bad and it's just
bad well while I'm smoking cigars and
going on shisha and drinking coffee and
I can't hypocritical to think like that
to me you know I mean you have to give
the real thing is I saying you know what
it's for babies it's really just you
know is used for fun as well I'm not
gonna lie to my kids and be like no it's
just for babies and you should just do
babies with that
that's not people don't do that in the
real life okay so that's pretty much it
so whenever you talk about something
yeah as protection yes there is STDs
pregnancies and stuff like that but
there's also downsides to that and it's
okay that you said that and I think it's
also important to know we can both
acknowledge the fact that there are
pressures to not use those protections
and also not the fact that music is also
not always as fun both for men and for a
lot of women as well you have a lot of
women like take it off I'm like I'm not
taking it off I have to keep it on right
so it's it's a reality and I'm just
joking about it but people get so
defensive and I just to me just strikes
me as odd that you feel so comfortable
to see some like such little what
acknowledging reality is what
acknowledge reality how many times do
women get up online and be like this man
didn't please me my whole point is that
you're entitled to be able to say like
yo my my bedroom life is not fulfilling
and that's okay and I understand but
then if I and to me experiences where
I've faked it the same way a lot of
women have had to fake it and people
asked why did you fake it because here's
the thing your partner wants to please
you and when they're not able to they
feel bad
so for me in order to avoid that awkward
interaction with the light I haven't
done a good job and I feel so terrible
I'm just like yeah it happened and we
move on cuz it's not that important to
me but I know it affects the other
person's pleasure when they've gotten
theirs
but they weren't able to even help you
get yours they feel terrible so that's
why I faked it it's just that and I
thought it was funny that I'm flushing
things down like a like a cop corrupt
cop hiding evidence that's all it was
but people got so hurt because of
whatever their past experience was or
whatever kind of societal pressures they
go through them but it's not talking
about that two things can be true at the
same time both protection can be
necessary and protection can be not fun
to use and it's funny because right now
he's just explained your joke yeah what
happens when you explain the joke yes
that we like when you dissect a frog
you understand the Frog better but it
dies in the process that was a funny
joke until you find it and just letting
you ladies know you're not the only ones
who fake it we fake it sometimes
absolutely we think it's something that
I hear often yeah thank you yeah just
want to end the experience is what it is
does you know why what but if a girl
doesn't you know whatever you didn't
please me but if you don't when you're
with a girl if you if you if you don't
when when you're with a girl the way
she's gonna feel is just gonna be so
much more devastating guys also feel
that way to a lot I'm not saying no yeah
yeah I'm saying no it's both partners
I'm telling understand that but this
proportion is the weight the Whitney Act
and the waiting Ellie so it's okay si si
good it's just a once I'm cooking a
while you fill in your body because man
orgasm is to them so easy to attain
compared to women of yeah orgasm when
she's dying hurts when we don't achieve
it it's like the whole world caramel and
I get that I understand it yeah if
you're chameleons also tell men there
was not we're not on the M is vacuuming
them they're not that Marcus can see
this get Isaiah leave a comment what's
my ability never in your life would you
accept someone coming in your DM and say
that that you say to me never in your
life forget that's a gift for me
but you're gonna come up in the DM
talking about yo who you think you are
never in your life you would call down
that mother quick if that person will
come up in your DM talking about your
energy little energy during the process
either the protest oh there's little
energy and they don't even understand
what the hell problematic with this you
know I mean don't talk about loose or
don't talk about you can't even talk
about how sometimes there's Barney order
that is myth you can't even say that but
you're gonna you're gonna go into
people's DM and talk about a whole
energy that's it for today's video we
want to hear your thoughts what do you
guys think about this topic yeah
[Music]